our Series pay attention looks at how to
retrain our focus and recapture our
attention under the bombardment of
technology and information that
distracts us the average person's rolls
through 300 feet of mobile content a day
that's about the equivalent of a
football field we wanted to explore some
of the ways people are trying to
short-circuit the noise from the mundane
to the extreme that's how I ended up
floating in a sensory deprivation tank
in Tulsa Oklahoma floating in less than
a foot of water buoyed by 2000 pounds of
salt I'm weightless I'm unsure where my
limbs end and the water starts and at
some point I lose myself never falling
asleep but moving into a state of a
clear but empty mind sensory deprivation
it's about as far as I can get from the
chirpy world of breaking news social
media email and the rest of what
pinball's through our kids all the
distractions that are in this world are
not in the tank for the past six months
entrepreneur Scott McKenzie has floated
three to six times a week
in Southern California to have that
nothingness and be forced to just
decompress there's something
revitalizing about it
McKenzie says that nothingness has
opened up his mind to new business ideas
what it does it keeps me more focused
you realize while like my mind had like
a whole reboot around since the 50s
floating is now resurfacing as an
alternative therapy for physical and
mental health
elite athletes like Golden State
Warriors Stefan curry claim it helps
with mental focus it's the only place
that I found in this world that you can
eliminate all you know all the senses
basically better to try to master your
thoughts you rarely ever find an
opportunity to do that the neat part
about floating is there's actually
nothing for you to do we met
neuropsychologist Justin Feinstein at
the laureate Institute for brain
research he studies the impact of
floatation therapy on patients with
anxiety disorders and PTSD welcome to
our open flow room we created a room
around the pool that was built to be
soundproof light proof temperature
controlled in fact we're trying to match
the temperature of the water to the
temperature of your skin okay which is a
few degrees cooler than core so about 95
degrees he is one of the few scientists
researching floating which is how I
ended up here in Tulsa Oklahoma we're
gonna turn you into a bionic man just do
this wearing a wireless waterproof EEG
on my forehead a heart rate monitor and
a blood pressure cuff in other words the
worst superhero Halloween costume if I
am in the busy world of constant
interruptions shredded attention how can
a good float help me with that
think about what a strange world our
brains find themselves in suddenly
inundated with 24/7 connectivity so here
in many ways you have the ultimate form
of disconnection while I marinated
feinstein monitored my vitals next door
my heart rate dropped by 20 beats a
minute and my blood pressure dropped
more than 20 points I was not asleep but
powered down to just a flicker by the
end of the float you were getting to
about two to three breaths a minute
which was incredibly low so low that
there is a biological effect on the
brain essentially telling it took quiet
down if you look at the first twenty one
twenty three minutes on the floor to
receive more activity which is not
uncommon
to relax neurophysiologist ricardo de
costa developed the technology that
measured my brain activity this is the
point when I turn off your lights this
is your brain relaxing after sixty five
minutes of floating in silent darkness I
was relaxed but also energized and I had
totally lost track of time
I could go for that every day I don't
think my office can fit that would be
great and now we're in the tank however
is not for everyone some people might
find that very restful some people might
find that it freaks them out dr. Philip
muskan is a psychiatrist at new
york-presbyterian Columbia University I
don't think it's for everyone the
problem in a busy day you're taking an
hour off to go to a floatation tank
where there are other things you could
do that might really benefit you in the
process of taking these breaks emptying
your mind help me control my attention
yes
attention is a biological phenomenon
when you empty your mind be that by
breath floatation meditation exercise it
works by allowing or brains to do some
discharge of the junk and let us go back
to work
I don't know if this is going to be the
solution ultimately to all of the
problems that technology may end up
causing our nervous system but it seems
like a very simple way to at least give
a respite Feinstein is in the middle of
his research it's still experimental the
big discovery would be if those who use
a float tank become so familiar with its
quietude that they can access it even
when they're not in the tank I thought
it was very cool it seems like the
ultimate in meditation I didn't like the
part where the top though comes down on
you I think that would creep me out a
little it's so dark the second time I
did it I just kept my eyes open and you
don't you can't see anything
mine I'm thinking next time wear your
speedo that will really enhance the
experience because we're because I think
let's close in there that actually
really dude when I did the second time
you're not wearing anything at all yeah
I could get that you can find out more
about the experience I'm not gonna be
able to get this picturing what it's
like to keep your eyes open for an hour
total darkness by visiting cBS This
Morning Calm I liked it a lot